ladies and gentlemen please thank you
people take your [ __ ] hats off and sit
down
my god there must be a million and a
half people here I tell you
it's j7 and the war on facts what the
[ __ ] is going on
I turned on my iPhone today to check the
news and Cherie said are you sitting
down but hey you know what we're still
here it was a big women's March on
Saturday huge you talked about you 3
million around the world there logged
the largest gathering of women since the
last time they collected the Bill Cosby
victims together very impressive
millions of women on all the continents
hugging crying and moaning it was like
the whole world turned into an Adele
concert it was awesome
because there's something happening and
you can feel it finally we have our own
Tea Party except with more teeth and no
spelling errors on the poster now of
course when President Trump heard right
outside the White House window the women
who were marching past him in greater
numbers than his own inauguration he
took it well I'm kidding of course he
got a bullhorn it started pointing out
their body flaws hey Chubby's you could
lose a few
you're a fool not interested and that's
the President of the United States and
then we got down to the actual business
of running a government which Donald
Trump apparently knows nothing about he
spent all week signing executive orders
and these super classy leather binders
that look at the menu at beefsteak
Charlie let's see I'll throw out the
Mexicans and bring back torture and the
lady will have the filet
he keeps holding them up you'll be after
he signs them like look look
yes mommy I
I finished my coloring maybe we could
put it on the refrigerator problem is
that you know executive orders are a
real thing when Obama did them he had
the lawyers go over it people knew what
was happening in the departments knowing
how these things are going to work no
one know where's the money coming up
they're just signed tweets you know
we're gonna build the law done no more
Obamacare done I want a pony dumb I mean
you know because he's a doer everybody
else is all talk so his first week was
like oh my god it was like the last half
hour of Goodfellas you know when Ray
Liotta is just coked out of his mind
doing ten things at once he's dropping
off a trunk full of handguns and he's
making spaghetti sauce and helicopters
are chasing Amit I can't
it can't really go on like this Brooks
for years cat it I mean I'm gonna lose
my mind I was watching CNN this morning
and I thought for the first time in my
life hey maybe I should ask my doctor of
abilify is right for me I mean there was
in just one week a lot to be very
alarmed about but you know I got to put
on the top of my list the fact that the
President of the United States sees
multitudes that do not exist twice he
did that in one week first he insisted
the crowd sighs at the inauguration was
the biggest ever and that aerial
photography is just a theory
but we saw this we saw these pictures
half them all covered in whiteness but
enough about his supporters I mean he
can't stand it that when it comes to the
size of the crowd Obama's was bigger
it's about talk right this is about dick
this is about a guy you never brought a
woman to orgasm that's what this is
about
he probably doesn't even think it really
exists and a woman it's rigged the
vaginas very rigged and then we're told
you know that there are such things as
alternative facts that's what this week
will be known for alternative facts and
Sean Spicer his press secretary about
the crowd sighs he just went this is
what the President believes you're on
your own
I think the difference between
Scientology and Donald Trump is
Scientology has better celebrities I do
here's how Sean Spicer explained
alternative facts he said it's like the
weather report one weather report comes
out and says it's going to be cloudy
another says there's going to be light
rain no one lied to you yeah you know
sometimes weatherman do disagree on what
the weather is going to be like tomorrow
but not on what it was like yesterday
and you know then as if seeing a million
people on the mall that weren't there
wasn't enough Donald Trump later in the
week says that there were three to five
million illegal aliens who voted for
Hillary Clinton when they studied this
dislike for five million how do we know
this
a German golf pro called a guy who told
a guy who told a guy in Donald Trump
heard it that the German guy was trying
to vote in Florida and couldn't possibly
because he's a German citizen but he saw
Hispanic looking people trying to vote
oh my god they must have been illegal
how else to explain a Hispanic in
Florida we're off to a great start with
the Hispanics the President of Mexico
was scheduled to visit here next week
but Trump's we didn't well if Mexico is
going to pay for the wall he Maas will
just cancel his trip and the Mexican
president said okay well you know what
Trump said he would keep the Mexicans
out there is one